Learning more about the lies.
New York Congressman
George Santos told as a younger man
about his family's
wealth and his business success.
His former roommate, Gregory
Marie Parker, joins us now.
And in full transparency,
a little technical difficulty th
And so we're glad you're here
that you're able to hear us
loud and clear. You're good.
Yes, I am. Good morning, Don.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Thank you so much for joining us
You knew Santos for a number of
starting in 2013.
How did you end up
living in the same house?
So my lease in Astoria was up in
and he was like, Oh, well,
you know,
the New York rental market is ri
Come stay with me for,
you know, a month or two
while we get everything
sorted out and try to find your
And I was like, Oh, okay.
So I took him up on it, moved in
It was definitely
an interesting, interesting few
Well, explain that to us.
What was he like back then?
What he said was interesting.
Well, he
I suppose the biggest thing
that I took away from
it was like just delusions of gr
Like he would just go to bars wi
you know, like rolls of $100 bil
and you know, three days later
he would have no money or,
you know, he would constantly be
oh, well,
you know, I'm going to sell my p
I'm going to sell my phone.
You know, anybody who wants to b
And you know, Michael,
why are you selling it?
And he's like, oh, well,
don't worry about it.
And it's just things just starte
continuously spiraling and getti
kind of ridiculously crazy.
You know, his mother was
a housekeeper and in Manhattan,
and it just didn't seem feasible
for him supposedly to come from
generational wealth, if you will
And what why is
why are you doing
the things that you're doing?
It doesn't make sense to me.
He was
he had made allegations
that he came from generational w
And you're saying
that his mother was a housekeepe
in the city in Manhattan?
Yeah.
So people are going to wonder.
And also,
you know, he he
you knew him through another nam
The last name, double. Yes.
I've I've I've always Don Imus,
the vulgar.
I've never known him as Jorge Sa
I was actually quite surprised,
I guess
he, you know, went by his middle
name and his mother's name.
But yeah,
no, I've
always known him,
as has the Anthony Travolta.
So, listen,
you know,
people are going to wonder
why you're coming out.
They're going to say, well,
that's his side of the story.
And do need to tell our viewers
that we did
reach out to Jorge Santos,
his representatives, his lawyers
and we haven't heard back from t
although we have been trying
since this story started
to get an interview with him.
He has declined,
his representatives have decline
and even his office in Washingto
You say something wasn't
adding up
between the way that Santos
talked about himself.
And the life that he led. Right.
About his name,
Anthony de Voltaire,
as you knew him, his wealth
and what have you.
What else doesn't add up? What e
Well, just, I.
I kind of assumed that he and ma
you know, about going to Baruch
but then I thought,
well, maybe I was wrong,
you know, after the election,
because I'm sure the de triple C
you know, and the RNC would have
you know, investigated Hamon.
At least
his opponent
would have done some research.
So I kind of thought,
well, maybe I'm wrong, you know,
maybe
this is just, you know, the trut
And I was incorrect.
But, I mean, obviously,
you know, the truth has finally
and I just I don't understand th
like one by one
to everybody in his district
and just to literally
pull the wool over their eyes
like how it's just flabbergastin
I'm wondering if this was the en
I guess it was a rocky relations
and it started off well and beca
this is, again, according to you
you believe that he stole
they stole a Burberry
scarf from you and wore it
when he gave a speech in D.C.
on January of 2021
this is January 5th, 20, 21,
one day before the capital attac
Now, CNN has not independently v
this claim in the speech centers
claim
that the 2020 congressional elec
was stolen from him.
Now you say this is not
you know
it's more than just a stolen sca
This is bigger than that.
Did he take other things?
And why are you saying this
is bigger than just a scarf?
Well, it just bothers me.
I mean,
he is one of the the, you know,
highest elected officials in the
You know,
he is responsible
for, you know, making the laws a
I mean, I,
I do miss my my son check Burber
But at the same time, it's
why I feel like
they're not focusing
enough on the issues at hand.
You know, where
where did all this money come fr
to finance the campaign?
You know, why
the whole thing is just it's
quite bewildering to me.
I mean, how he even got elected.
Well, we we appreciate you joini
this morning. Gregory and Maury
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having